home sweet home niemals hätte Luis hemfy
gedacht dass sie sich mal so über ein
ein Zimmer Apartment freuen würde klein
fein mein 45 Quadratmeter sie und ihr
Freund Joe legen dafür umgerechnet 1600
Euro kaltmieter auf den Tisch weit
draußen in London beide haben studiert
gute Jobs sind Anfang 30 fündig wurden
sie nach zwei Monaten suchen dutzenden
Besichtigung für die sie manchmal
bezahlen mussten sowie hunderte
Mitbewerber und 6 Monate Mieten im
Voraus keine Seltenheit
bei einer Besichtigung habe ich gesucht
aber es gab keine Küche man musste
wirklich einen Schrank öffnen da war so
etwas wie ein Spülbecken eine Mikrowelle
und der Kühlschrank ich dachte nur oh
mein Gott wer lebt denn ein Sofas
auch deshalb schaut die 33-Jährige in
ihrer Bude über einiges hinweg
der Boiler nach zwei Monaten repariert
trotzdem nur lauwarmes Wasser
Kühlschrank kaputt doch der Vermieter
lässt sich nicht blicken besser so
erklärt Luis nicht dass er auf die Idee
kommt die Miete zu erhöhen denn später
eingezogene Nachbarn Zahlen schon 500 €
mehr für die gleiche Größe
das Haus war früher ein Bürogebäude im
Winter ist es deshalb verrückt was
Feuchtigkeit und Schimmel betrifft ich
meine feucht und schimmlig das gehört zu
britischen Wohnung irgendwie dazu ich
habe noch nie irgendwo gelebt wo das
nicht der Fall war aber hier waren wir
morgens auf und das Wasser läuft in
Strömen von den Fenstern runter wenn du
den Schimmel mit Spezialreinigern
entfernst kommt er ein paar Tage später
wieder die Wände hochgekochen
immerhin müssten sie nicht zurück zu den
Eltern ziehen denn fast 4 Millionen
Erwachsene Leben in England im Hotel
Mama 700.000 mehr als vor zehn Jahren
die Gründe für die Mieten die Serie
nicht nur in London im ganzen Land sei
eine verfehlte Politik erklärt
stadtplanungs-
vor 30 Jahren wurde der soziale
Wohnungsbau quasi eingestellt Millionen
erschwinglicher Sozialwohnungen durften
verkauft werden seitdem regelt der Markt
dort die Mietpreise und die steigen
momentan so stark wie nie
London geben mittlerweile im Schnitt
mehr als die Hälfte ihres Einkommens für
das Wohnen aus
Studien zeigen dass man sobald man mehr
als ein Drittel dafür hinlegen muss
verstärkt unter psychischen Problemen
leidet
wir sind zweifellos in einer furchtbaren
Wohnungskrise in London und ganz
Großbritannien
der Markt regelt das ein Mantra auf der
Insel natürlich werde in Britannien
Städten gebaut zum Minden London etwa
sei voller Kräne
sind verkauft bevor sie gebaut werden
auf großen internationalen
immobilienmessen
zu Preisen die sich Einheimische nicht
mal ansatzweise leisten könnten
Teile Londons stehen immer leer Wohnraum
der als Geldanlage oder
Spekulationsobjekt dient nur mit einem
großen Eingriff der Politik in den Markt
könne das Problem angegangen werden
ergänzt permanenten mietpreisdeckel ein
umfangreiches soziales
Wohnungsbauprogramm und der Kampf gegen
Spekulanten und Mietpreis Haie deren
Opfer wurde Lynn pamel die ihre
Obdachlosigkeit versucht zu genießen so
die Rentnerin im Campervan ihrem neuen
Zuhause in Margate an der Küste zwei
Autostunden von London nachdem sie aus
ihrer Wohnung rausgeworfen wurde hat sie
alle Wertsachen verkauft davon den Geist
der Freiheit so der Spitzname ihres
Zimmers auf Rädern bezahlt was habe ich
zu verlieren meine Rente plus
wohnzuschuss hätten nicht mal für ein
Zimmer gereicht dazu die sonstigen
Ausgaben ich hätte so nicht überleben
können denn auch die
Lebenshaltungskosten steigen und steigen
Strom Gas all die anderen Rechnungen
eine Mieterhöhung von ungerechnet 500
auf 820 Euro wurde Lünen zum Verhängnis
sie war Fitnesstrainerin hat ihre
demente Mutter gepflegt die Rente reicht
nun für Sprit 12 Euro am Tag fürs Essen
und geduscht wird bei Freunden
ihre Erlebnisse teilt sie auf tiktok wo
ihr mehr als 55.000 Folgen vielen davon
drohe das gleiche Schicksal macht es wie
ich Krise als Chance lacht sie darüber
werde sie noch ein Buch schreiben
ich bin kein wütender Charakter und sehe
immer das Positive wie es mir gerade
geht naja ich bin okay mal sehen wie das
in sechs Monaten ist wenn der Winter
mich frieren lässt
ihre Story sei ja schon fast romantisch
bis kitschig aber gerade für die jungen
sei das doch ganz anders
ich halte durch solange es geht wer weiß
schon was als nächstes kommt
Ruhe bewahren weitermachen durch
wurschteln ist der ungemütliche kalte
Winter kommt
ein warmes Eigenheim kaufen das haben
auch Luis und Joe durchgerechnet
utopisch die waghalsige Finanzpolitik
der Regierung hat im vergangenen Jahr
die Kreditzinsen in die Höhe getrieben
kein Wunder so Louis dass die
Konservativen gerade von jungen Wählern
verschmäht werden
ich würde das Land so gerne verlassen
ich habe zwei Jahre in der Schweiz
studiert und was ich mit der meisten
bereue ist dass ich mich damals nicht
mehr reingehängt habe um einen Job in
der Schweiz zu finden was vor dem brexit
war da hätte ich bleiben können
wohnen mieten kaufen in Großbritannien
ist das auf dem besten Weg zur Sache der
Reichen und Schönen zu werden die
mächtigen allerdings die konservative
Regierung könnte der Mangel an
bezahlbaren Wohnraum im kommenden Jahr
aus dem Amt wegen
[Musik]